E aí tô aqui doente né decide Sabe por
que que eu tô assim porque eu sou homem
homem é desse jeito é dramático mulher
não mulher quando tá doente você pode
ter certeza que tenha muito tempo que
ela tá sentindo alguma coisa só depois
que ela vai falar contigo porque ela
suporta minha mãe tem 30 anos que a
cabeça dela dói 30 anos ela nunca tomou
um Dorinho todo dia ela fala inglês
minha cabeça até doendo e vai viver a
vida dela agora homem Ave Maria doeu a
barriga amor ai amor amor amor minha
barriga
[Risadas]
isso era peido ó gás preso não era nada
não o metro dramático ou a mulher vem
espremer Um cravo cara não sai sai sai
deixa não não